finally i heard about this amazing
athlete from
one of my favorite magazines oprah
magazine um by the way did anyone ever
listen to oprah radio
it was on siriusxm it's since gone but
all throughout both of my pregnancies
with my daughters i feel like both of my
girls have the oprah
radio energy in their souls because
that's all i did was listen to oprah
radio
and um so they're talking about gigi
lucas who's a woman
with the surfing bug and she's passed it
on to the next generation
so the founder of surf feyer negra she's
sending young girls of color to surf
camps and teaching them
ocean safety and she's taking a break
from the waves today to be here with us
hi gigi
as a mother of daughters and a lover of
oprah we were so excited that you would
come on the show
and um is am i correct in the research
um that the crew did for me they always
get it right that it was
a moment in costa rica that sent the
light bulbs off about surfing for you
yes it was i actually was born in
florida
on the west coast and my parents raised
catamarans so i was always a water baby
but actually didn't come to surfing
until i was adult an adult and when i
went to costa rica on a destination
wedding i decided to take a surf lesson
and drew when i stood up on that board
and started sliding on the face of the
wave that was all she wrote
so you had this amazing moment with
surfing in costa rica you're from
florida you're a water
baby but why did you want to transfer
that out to other girls
sure um i mean for the longest time when
i was learning how to surf i
noticed that i was usually the only
woman definitely the only black woman in
the lineup and i realized that
as i started learning more about
american history there is a reason why
girls of color
have disconnected with the ocean and so
when i founded serbia negra which is a
501c3 i wanted to make sure that the
mission was to make surfing accessible
to any kid anywhere and as it stands
right now we have
two main programs um one is 100 girls
program which is a fun that literally
sends girls of color to surf camp
we have about 74 camps partner camps in
our network across 48 states
and thankfully drew um to date we've
been able to send 64 girls to camp but
our goal is to send 100 girls or more
girls to camp every summer
let's please work together to keep
spreading the word and shine a light on
this
you are amazing thank you so much